je savais je portais une parole qui
allait changer éventuellement les choses
2 mars 1990 sur le plateau de l'émission
apostrophes la romancière canadienne
denise bombardier fustige en direct
l'écrivain gabriel m'atteler moi
monsieur matzneff me semble pitoyable
dans son livre mes amours des composés
il témoignait de ses relations sexuelles
avec de très jeunes filles pourquoi vous
êtes vous spécialiser dans les lycéennes
les mines est au dessus de 20 ans voit
que ça ne vous intéresse plus mon cher
c'est la réciprocité aussi qui est vrai
je n'ai jamais eu aucun succès auprès
des femmes de 25 30 et plus des femmes
installés dans la vie trente et un ans
plus tard denise bombardier revient sur
ce moment de télévision net nous raconte
qui ce domaine des petites filles de 14
à 15 que ces petites filles sont folles
de lui ces bonus on y mangeait rien
j'avais rien écrit à bord on sait bien
que des petit fils filles peuvent être
folle d'un monsieur qui a une certaine
aura littéraire d'ailleurs on sait que
les vieux monsieur attire les petits
enfants avec des bonbons monsieur
matzneff nuit les attire avec sa
réputation sur le plateau l'écrivaine
était la seule à réagir face à elle des
rires et de la complaisance est quand
même un collectionneur de minettes et
alors par exemple la conquête en trois
jours consécutifs de trois inconnus dont
deux vierge marie agnès mode et 7
brigitte s avec qui j'ai fait l'amour
toute les façon quasi sans interruption
à l'époque il y avait une tolérance
vis-à-vis la pédophilie dans un milieu
protégé de gens qui
avaient un pouvoir dans la société
française qui contrôlait les journaux et
qui contrôlait les maisons d'édition si
c'est un beau livre la ligue on ne pas
ne peut pas servir des soli même à la
littérature quelques jours après ce vif
échange gabriel matzneff est de nouveau
invité sur un plateau avec son ami
l'écrivain philippe sollers et voilà
comment il qualifiait denise bombardier
parce que la codah ce qu'on vient
d'entendre
non ça c'est encore dans un procès sa
feria je dois je répète la [ __ ]
combien entendre qu'ils canadienne je
crois qu ils raisonnent comme ça à la
télévision et j'ai été traité de tous
les noms à paris j'ai été démolies dans
une partie des journaux et ça fait 2
tours de de toutes les rédactions
parisiennes j'ai peut-être une mal
baisées 31 ans plus tard deux femmes ont
brisé le silence vanessa spring aura et
francesca ji dans leurs livres
respectifs
elle accuse gabriel matzneff dans prix
sexuelle lorsqu'elle était mineure et
vous imaginez les efforts vous imaginez
les douleurs qu'il y a chez ces deux
femmes et qui ont été capables d'écrire
là-dessus gabriel matzneff est
actuellement visé par une enquête pour
viol sur mineure en septembre 2021 il
devait être jugé pour apologie de la
pédocriminalité le procès a finalement
été annulée pour erreur de procédure
[Musique]